-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy Award-winning actor,
screenwriter, and producer
you know
from shows like "Six Feet Under"
and "The Leftovers."
He stars
in "The Mosquito Coast,"
which premieres on Apple TV+
with the first two episode
this Friday.
Let's take a look.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Door bursts open ]
-[ Gasps ]
[ Music continues playing
-Where is it?
-Where's what?
-Dina?
-[ Scoffs ]
-Is he gone?
-Oh, no, he's still here, Josh
How you doin'?
Please welcome back to the sho
Justin Theroux.
How are you, Justin?
-Hey, man, how are ya?
-It is really genuinely nice
to see you.
We have not seen each othe
for a long time,
which is very strange.
We are neighbors.
We live very close.
My wife and I famously saw you
about an hour
before she gave birth
to a child in the lobby.
-You and Alexi
were walking in the park.
I know.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'm part of your birth story.
-You are very much
a part of our birth story.
But I have not seen you at all
How have you been?
-I've been good.
I've been really good.
I've been here most of the time.
You know, the whole thing.
Even oftentimes I would look
into your windows,
thinking you were there, and -
I wasn't looking into
your windows like a creep.
-No, like a cool guy.
-And then I would see you --
Yeah, like a cool guys
looks in the window.
And they would be darkened
and I would be sad.
And I would be upset about that.
But I miss you
in the neighborhood.
And I would love to see you.
-I actually
have had this happen.
Look, you and I, we are
in show business,
and we know that sometimes
you will have something going on
where a car will be sent
to pick you up.
-Yes.
-And I was walking by
your building,
and I saw one of those cars.
And I thought, "Oh,
I bet this is for Justin.
And maybe I'll wait and say hi."
But then I realized
I was the creep,
'cause the driver
was just looking at me.
And I'm a guy in a mask
who just stopped.
And I said, "You know what
I'm gonna..."
-And your Sharpie.
-"I'm gonna keep walking."
This was something, the timing
obviously was not ideal,
but you managed
to make it through.
You opened a bar in the city
in 2019.
How did you manage through
not, obviously, a great year
for a bar?
-Well, no,
it was not a great year.
Well, you know, it's --
Look, we were fine
with not turning a profit
last year.
Obviously, like everybody,
it was more about
just sort of making sure
that everyone
got to keep their job.
We shut down only
for a couple months, actually.
And then Mr. de Blasio
was doing a bang-up job
by opening up the city.
Let us open again
and serve booze outside,
which also is not ideal
in the cold winter months.
But, yeah, everyone
was basically able
to sort of maintain.
We were able
to keep the bar open.
So, now, it's wildly open,
and we've almost kind of doubled
the outdoor space now,
which is really fun.
We've kind of -- We're quickly
making our way back.
But, you know,
it was that thing --
It was actually kind of cool
all the restaurants and bars
all kind of started doing,
like -- you know,
sort of, I guess, collabs,
for lack of a better word,
where we'd serve burgers
or pizzas from --
you know,
a Brooklyn pizza place.
Or we'd have, you know --
Yeah, we just -- we would do
like, food and drinks
and stuff.
We were able to keep
the whole thing afloat.
-I will say, yesterday
was a very warm night
in New York City,
and as I was leaving the show,
a day after
the CDC basically said
you don't have to wear a mas
outside,
New York felt 100% back,
last night.
-I know, and especially
over where we live,
where there's also
a lot of the U's,
the park started to just loo
like a Berlin summer festiva
or something.
[ Both laugh ]
It was so schizophrenic.
People, like, skateboardin
and doing wheelies
and light sticks
and all the rest of it.
-I felt like an old man,
where I was like,
"I miss the old days,
when the kids
had to stay inside."
-"Kids!" [ Laughs ]
-Hey, you let your dog
come to the bar.
-All the time, yeah.
-And we have
very different dogs,
but very similar colorings
on our dogs.
-I've only heard about your dog.
-Yeah.
-What's your dog's name again?
-Frisbee.
And Frisbee doesn't go out much,
because she gets cold
right away.
But I feel like our dogs are
like, the same color
but very different.
[ Laughter ]
-Your dog looks like the
dehydrated version of my dog
[ Laughter ]
-If you made --
Yeah, that's like --
If you made dog jerky out
of that,
it would look like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Your dog looks like taxidermy
with a broken ear.
[ Laughter ]
-How dare you!
-I kid with Frisbee.
-Of course.
Hey, so, this is really cool
"The Mosquito Coast,"
it's great.
I did not know that your uncle
was Paul Theroux,
who wrote this book
40 years ago
and is a wonderful author,
who I love a great deal.
And one of the reasons I think
it never occurred to me
he was your uncle
is that you say your
last names differently.
-This is a whole thing.
I mean, it's not a whole thing
but it's a thing.
You know, he says --
It's a French name.
And originally, when I
check into a hotel in France
they say, "Oh, bonjour,
Monsieur 'Teroo.'"
So it's got
a hard "T" sound on it.
Then, I guess,
when he came over,
to be easier, made it "Ther-oo."
And then, I guess, growing up,
no one really
got my name correctly.
Sort of, the neighborhood
chose my name.
And I'm not gonna go up agains
the whole neighborhood,
so they would just say
"Thoreau,"
or teachers
would mispronounce it.
You know, "Where is Justin
Therux," or whatever.
So, wherever it landed, that's
kind of what I stuck with.
And then it was too late.
And only now
that we're doing a show together
has this resurfaced
as creating a schism
in our family.
-Did he know this was happenin
behind the scenes?
I know sometimes, as an author
you're not familiar
or up-to-date
with what's happening.
-No.
It looks like
it's something
we cooked up together,
but it was one of those things
that one of my managers said
"You know, they're doing
'The Mosquito Coast'?
It just popped up on our radar."
And I thought, "Oh,
that's interesting,
I'd like to read that script."
And then I read it,
and then I said,
"It's a really good script
I'd like to do this."
So I met with Neil Cross, an
then I met with Apple.
And then --
And then I sort of --
We went down the road, and
I ended up signing up for it
And then I just called --
I got to call him and say,
"Guess what?
Guess what I'm doing with you.
And it was just sort of
a happy accident.
You know, it wasn't planne
in that way.
-That's just wonderful.
This had been a film
almost, I guess,
like 30 or 40 years ago,
as well,
starring Harrison Ford.
This is even maybe
a bigger shock to me
than the fact
that Paul is your uncle.
While you were filming this,
you randomly met Harrison Ford
for the first time.
-Yes, totally.
I was in Mexico City
and staying at a hotel,
and he happened to come in
to do something else,
and a friend of ours
notified us, "Hey, you kno
Harrison Ford's --"
or a mutual friend --
that he's in the hotel.
And I thought, "Oh, can we
have dinner or something,
or a cup of coffee?"
They said,
"Let me put it together."
And they put it together.
And we had this --
you know, one of those
private dining room situations
where we just had
a ton of tacos and tequila
and just sat and gabbed
and had, like,
a really long, great, slightly
drunken night together.
And it was fabulous.
It's exactly what you would want
a long dinner with Harrison Ford
to be like.
It's like -- It was just -
He's such a charmer.
He's a lovely man.
-That is fantastic.
And it is very cool that you are
playing the same part as him
And it's always great
to see you, buddy.
I hope it happens
on the street soon.
-I hope so, too, man.
-Alright, all the best.
"The Mosquito Coast" premieres
globally on Apple TV+,
with the first two episode
tomorrow,
followed by new episodes
every Friday.